the las vegas raiders have just about
filled all the holes in their roster
sports director chris matthews joins us
with more on a few of those who
want to be raiders this season chris
yeah that's good news it's
amazing to see we see las vegas raiders
isn't it certainly seems like it'd be
tough to
turn down an opportunity to play for the
silver and black especially with all the
amenities now provided
by playing for the raiders today they
introduced center nick martin now he's
wearing number 66
in these highlights might not be a
flashy skill position player
but for those running backs and
quarterbacks to succeed you need a
strong line
martin comes to las vegas after playing
five years with the texans
he started all 16 games for three
straight years and blocked for a rushing
attack
that averaged nearly five yards of carry
second most in franchise history
and if you get a guy like martin you're
getting a guy who can't wait to play
in las vegas i'm so excited to be here
in las vegas
and you know i'm just going to come here
and compete and excited to have an
opportunity man that's the nfl that's
all you can ask for
you can tell everyone just loves ball
here and that's my passion i love
football
and i'm very excited to be a part of it
now i'm more focused on las vegas
raiders and excited to be a part of this
with you know a great running back of
josh jacobs raiders also making it
official that they've signed richie
incognito denzel good it seems like
those spots they need to fill
well right guard now safety and perhaps
a cornerback so
they've almost got all those spots to
fill they might do it through the draft
and speaking of the draft pro day in los
angeles at usc today and reportedly mike
mayok was in attendance
on friday b-y-u holding a pro day nfl
scouts look at about six to seven
players from
the provost school